great to have you great to see you again
well it's lovely to be here yes being an
Irish month and I'm your welcoming me
into your home
oh yes yes we love having brought you a
gift okay look at it I was tricky
together is this is this the actual can
you explain to us how this happened on
Game of Thrones it is the most
meticulous show in the world and they
left a a Starbucks cup on the set during
a pivotal scene why that wasn't a
pivotal decision the cup was a bit more
pivotal than the scene these things
happen it's a big job people run in an
Amelia probably drinks too much coffee
yeah I see I see so you weren't shocked
by it but I think the show survived it
show survived the big coffee country yes
I think just about we can moved on let's
talk about there's so much talk about
talking about props
Isaac Hempstead Wright was here mm-hmm
and he told us that he took some stuff
from the set different people were
taking different mementos from the set
just to remember Game of Thrones because
of sending but he said you took more
than anyone else that you took a massive
haul from the Game of Thrones set is
that true sir is it true when you say
take I take is an ugly word like stole
[Laughter]
liberated you liberated yeah I did I did
[Applause]
yeah I did they did catch me on the last
season but a flatbed truck but I do have
a have a list of stuff where'd you get
just tell us what you got well enough
that my daughter has a place for it and
she calls it the wall of Awesome I did
get I got a full-size Dothraki sword Wow
yeah I've also got what I casually
referred to as my scrotum which was it
away no it's there the the bag that my
finger bones were in at the in season
two
oh yes yes so nice to get that I've got
money I've got I've also got the very
sadly there that you guys remember the
stag that I curved for Shireen yeah and
I've also got the burnt stag the one
that I find when I when I discover how
she died and and on various other stuff
yeah that's a really good haul because
Isaac Hempstead right said that he just
took a little wicker basket and he got
it home and realized it looks like any
other wicker basket he basically said oh
yeah it looks like he's just some in
this game a long time just looks like he
went to the mall